what i want to do in this video is to
see if we can understand all of the
different parts of kind of a a
traditional income statement and as we
get into more and more complicated
examples you'll see more and more
complicated income statements but this
is a good start so what i've done here
is i've drawn the income statements for
actually two businesses one is ben's
shoes and one is adjacent shoes and i
did that because these are fundamentally
the same business but they have a
slightly different capital structure and
we'll talk about what that means in a
second but they're both shoe stores they
they literally you know they buy shoes
from shoe manufacturers they put them on
their shelves and then customers come in
and buy those shoes so the first line
we're pretty familiar with it already
this is the revenue this is the sales
for each of these shoe stores in the
case of a shoe store it's literally just
going to be a measure of the cash that
the the customers are paying for the
shoes you wouldn't have you know
something like accounts receivables
where people can pay months later most
of it will just be cash cost of goods
sold
in this example we're just going to
assume it to be the actual cost of a
shoe if i
sold a pair of hundred dollar shoes but
i had to pay 50 to the shoe manufacturer
for those shoes that 50 would be the
cost of goods sold so this hundred
thousand dollars is actually the cost of
the two hundred thousand dollars in in
sales and when you just take the cost of
goods sold from that revenue you get
something called gross profit and really
the focus of this is of this video is to
try to understand the different gross
profit operating profit pre-tax income
net income and so gross profit is the
first time that you kind of think of
profit and the reason why it's called
gross is because we've just thought
about the profit from selling that
incremental shoe and sometimes some
other costs are thrown in there
sometimes advertising sometimes the the
cos some other cost associated with the
store but for this example it's just the
profit straight from selling that
incremental shoe and that's why we call
it growth since we haven't taken out
other things yet
then below that line we have all of the
other expenses the expenses associated
with running the store the kind of the
overhead of running that store so we
have the rent you have the salaries you
have the depreciation and amortization
maybe you're depreciating the cost of
your cash register and the shelves and
and whatever else and then you could
have other things like utilities and you
can see both ben's shoes and jason shoes
are completely identical up to this
point they have the same revenue gross
profit even the same expenses
and so when you take all of these
expenses out from the gross profits you
take 100 000 minus all of these and i've
written all the stuff that you subtract
with parentheses out around them to show
that these are expenses that these are
negatives you get the operating profit
and you see that both of these are the
same number
and what operating profit tells you is
how much profit is coming from the
business it's before we think about how
the business is structured it doesn't
think about things like interest income
from your bank account or interest
expense on any loans you have it's from
the business itself operating profit and
since these are identical businesses
they have the same exact operating
profit where they start to diverge is
below that line so above this line right
over here is the income statement down
here is the balance sheet and their
balance sheets are identical except for
jason's shoes has a hundred thousand
dollars in debt
and ben shoes has no debt so ben has no
interest expense while jason does have a
ten thousand dollar interest expense so
it's about ten percent per year and
that's why these two income statements
start to diverge but notice we didn't
put this expense up there because it has
nothing to do with the operations it's
dependent on how the operations were
financed and so once you subtract that
out then you actually have your pre-tax
income and if we assume that we have to
pay taxes this is how much we pay in
taxes and this is actually the net
income that goes to the owners of the
company